if there was one thing you could have
people experience with your game perhaps
in the same way that you did with leaves
from there what would it be what would
it be and they're like that you're
having now your own telling your own
story you know that it's so vast that
it's just obvious to you that no one
could possibly be doing what you're
doing
the universe of no man's sky is
incredibly vast unfathomably so dwarfing
even the scale of games like EVE Online
today on the next big game we analyze
how the scale of no man sky as the
possibility to give us a gaming
experience we've never had before
I played originally and quite quite
obsessively my dad basically had a he
worked for a electronics company he had
a PC which was like amazing in this days
like green screen and and he had like he
was obsessed with it as well and he had
all these amazing save games and and so
yeah I did it was just just one of my
one of the most kind of amazing kind of
experiences
I think when I was thinking about the
game you know which I have since like
embarrassingly since I've been a kid you
kind of think thinking about this type
of game you know it was exactly that
like these worlds and experiences that
you read about in sci-fi you could never
you could never visit those worlds right
you could never escape to them you can
never see what it would be like all of
it and you never will be able to write
and it's something that a book can kind
of deliver and fire your imagination but
it's not the same as like that feeling
of actually walking around something
that no one else has discovered
something at some place that no one else
has been to and that's a real kick and a
film can't deliver that a book can't
deliver that but a game can
and they don't generally the thing that
we're doing a lot with games is they're
really proscribed and they're really
heavily designed and they're corridor
ladder things of that and so you never
get that feeling but the one thing I
would like no man's sky to be able to do
is deliver that feeling of you know I
have landed on a planet and no one else
has ever been here and I'm seeing
something that no one else has seen and
there are moments when I'm playing the
game now when I was flying or hand the
universe as it is at the moment
searching for a place to stage the demo
and you know that you do you get that
feeling and you're just like you know
discovering so then like a guy's ever
loved
no man sky's universe is assembled by a
vast array of math and procedural
generation systems which the team at
hello games had spent the best part of a
year putting together the universe is
constant it's the same for everyone but
what's hidden I need to planet is a
mystery even to the developers the
planets and fauna and especially the
color colors is just stunning how do you
how do you do that with a procedural
system the visible possibly picking all
this stuff around is quite tricky a lot
of what we are actually doing is kind of
trying to control this procedural system
so it because I can do so much akin and
it's doing all these a factory infinite
variations of things that we are
obviously doing that will produce a
really really terrible looking if I
wasn't terrible looking you know color
combinations and things so Shawn to me
created these robots which can we worry
about further you know simulated robot
who can fly down to each planet and they
record like a little animated gif and
what we end up with is just a page of
thumbnails you see we've got animated
gif robot drone it flies down to flatten
and record see a little flight through
so it's the same for a perfuming being
to do that I could take ages that we
just it's a really nice way of us being
able to view a crazy amount of visual
data without having to do it muddies
this procedural system allows the team
to create infinite permutations of flora
fauna spaceships and planets systems
that are connected the chemicals that
exist in a planet air to find the color
of its atmosphere the amount of water
changes the way in which land is formed
where beaches are it's an entirely new
way to build virtual worlds part of why
we don't say as well it's exactly this
and there will be this many creatures of
ships is because you know and I've shown
you mister this those limits don't apply
usually
right and so we don't have to work to
those we're not restrained by content
anymore which is really freely but also
part of it is like we want people to
explore we don't want so many people
have asked us like how many levels can
you upgrade your weapon and so for that
it's like let's not tell people that
let's people discover that you know to
me and kind of talk about it yeah with
my favorite thing in like minecraft
isn't like a big reference point for us
or anything like that but I do it has
some parts that I just really admire
like minecraft never told you what the
formulas were for crafting things I
don't think I ever would have done that
as a designer right bold move but it's
so cool you know it's just so nice for a
game to just go figure it out because
that's the game that I grew up with as a
kid you know you would just load a game
into your like commodore 64 year round
strat or whatever and you would have to
press all the buttons to figure out like
you'd press everything on the keyboard
to figure out what things did you know
to me and i like that and and people are
cleverer than what games designers think
if i was to take one thing away from
this project from seeing the game in
action from talking to the guys at e3
it's that wonder is really important to
them in creating a universe where people
might not meet each other where planets
may go uncovered forever they are
creating something that hasn't really
ever existed in games a world that most
games pretend to make a game without
boundaries hello games aren't interested
in spilling the beans on this game we're
talking about specific mechanics or
features they want to retain its sense
of wonder so that we can all enjoy it at
launch and I think that's pretty brave
thank you for spending time with us here
on our wonderful alien forest but the
next big game no man's sky isn't over
just yet
tomorrow Karen Robinson sits down with
Sean Murray to talk about building
procedural universes and shows off the
dev tools they built every tree creature
planet and ship in no man's sky
you